في الحقيقه يعني حتى هذه اللحظه اليوم
نسمع ان هناك مساعدات هي موجوده حاليا في
معبر باب الهوى سوف تدخل باتجاه شمال غرب
سوريا ولكن حتى تاريخ هذه اللحظه التي
اتحدث معك بها لم نتلقى اي مساعده الا من
فريق تقني هو فريق لا يملك معدات لا يملك
اليات وصل الى شمال غرب سوريا عن طريق
معبر باب الهوى مع منظمه التركيه هو الان
يعمل مع فرق البحث والانقاذي هو هذا
الفريق على عدد من الاطباء هم
المتواجدون الان في المشافي وباقي الفريق
هو من يملك من خبرات في البحث والانقاذ
انضم الى فريق القوه البيضاء في منطقه
جنديرس وهو الان موجود على الارض يعمل مع
فريق البيضاء نحن كنا نناشد وننادي هناك
72 ساعه ذهبيه هذه 72 ساعه ضروري جدا ان
يكون هناك مساعدات يكون هناك اليات اضافيه
معدات لرفع الانقاذ من اجل سحب العالقين
من تحت الانقاذ للاسف عندما نتجاوز هذه 72
ساعه يتحول العمل من سحب عالقين الى
انتشال ضحايا من تحت الانقاض وهذا الامر
الذي كنا لا نريد ان نصل اليه